son prix de départ était fixé à 300.000
euros une Rondo
m482 un bolide qui a participé à 5 fois
au 24 Heures du Mans était proposé aux
enchères ce week-end à l'hôtel des vents
Giraudeau une voiture de compétition qui
pouvait atteindre 355 km/h alors les
connaisseurs ont-ils fait monter les
enchères la réponse dans ce reportage de
Florent Clavel
2 300 km/h sur la piste à 300.000 euros
aux enchères 40 ans après sa première
course la rando m482 fait de nouveau
grimper les compteurs et tournez les
têtes c'est une voiture assez mythique
vous trouvez qu'elle est bien partie oui
elle est bien partie et une belle une
belle somme dans les années 80 le bolide
a participé à cinq reprises au 24 Heures
du Mans alors à deux mois du centenaire
de la mythique course d'endurance le
prototype conçu est piloté par le
français Jean Rondeau fait vibrer les
passionnés j'ai vu cette voiture là
courir en 82 j'étais en commissaire dans
ligne droite c'est le dernier prototype
qui avait fait Rondeau avec effet de sol
et il voulait concurrencer les Porsche
962 s'il sportive et puis faut vraiment
l'avoir bien comme il faut pour conduire
ça
à côté de la Rondeau une Ferrari de 340
chevaux pilotés quelques années par un
Prost ou encore une Deutsch bonnet de
1953 qui chante encore parfaitement
au total une quarantaine de voitures
mises aux enchères par l'étude
tourangelle Giraudot comme celle qui a
une fois par an
on avait un fond fond de vente c'est à
dire un collectionneur qui était prêt à
vendre quelques voitures phares de sa
collection dont la Rondeau la DB et les
Ferrari et donc autour de ce beau noyau
on a communiqué et puis c'est greffer un
ensemble de véhicules d'amateurs de
collectionneurs qui sont déjà une vente
on en profite et puis du coup on a
décidé de faire cette bande cette vente
aujourd'hui
mon dos est finalement à juger 318000
euros soit le prix d'une belle maison un
acheteur tout en jaune passionné
forcément